think when we saw the trailers that kind
of high drama the pace of those at the
start of episode one you do get some of
that and this sense of them being chased
out of the UK the fact that they didn't
feel protected all of the paparazzi
around them all of the lenses on them
but then it does kind of slow down and
as you were talking about there there is
this kind of sense of taking us inside
the love story about how they had this
very treasured relationship that they
wanted to try and keep to themselves but
Harry does I think lay it on thick and I
think for him really this is kind of a
kind of cathartic experience some of
this stuff we've heard him say in the
past but he is going into a lot more
detail where he talks about lots of his
childhood memories basically being
surrounded by the paparazzi and that's
kind of how his childhood is there in
his mind so you can then immediately
realize why he kind of became this real
alpha male when he met Megan when he
wanted to do everything he could to
possibly protect her he talked talks
about at the start of the episode one I
feel as though being part of this family
it's my duty to uncover this
exploitation and bribery which happens
within our media Megan says
unfortunately by standing for something
they're destroying us and then Harry
goes on to say this has always been so
much bigger than us no one knows the
full truth we know the full truth the
institution know the full truth so
pretty damning about the Royals there
and the media know the full truth
because they've been in on it so this
sense of of collusion going on and I
think that anyone else in my situation
would have done exactly the same thing
now also in episode two a really
interesting quote which I've just come
across now where and I think this is
particularly bad for the royal family
really and this is where he's making
direct comments at them he says he's
talking about kind of the racism claims
against Megan and how they didn't feel
protected and he says what people need
to understand is as far as a lot of the
family were concerned everything she was
being put through they'd been put
through as well so it was almost like a
rite of passage at that point you see
pictures of Diana and Fergie and Kate
and some members of the royal family he
said were like my wife had to go through
that so why should your girlfriend be
treated any differently why should you
get special treatment why should she be
protected and I said the difference here
is the race element and of course you
can't forget that from the Oprah
interview it was those allegations of
racism within the palace allegations
that of course we heard last week
relating to a domestic violence
reception and it's the racism element I
think is particularly toxic for the
royal family whether or not in these
kind of series these elements that we
see now whether or not they're all
family fear they have to respond I'm not
sure there doesn't seem to be new
evidence so yeah we wait to see what the
royal family decide that they need to to
respond to these first three episodes or
not okay Rihanna thanks Steve what do
you make of that well I I agree with
Ariana and totally I my feeling is the
royal family won't respond till we've
seen all six because you can't keep
going on I mean Netflix are a
professional filmmaking outfit you can't
keep going on with the same story we had
to wear disguises we had to hide
ourselves we couldn't you know face life
with the paparazzi the way they were and
he's obsessed about bribery and the
British press but in fact certainly in
in the first and second the beginning of
the second issue they're talking about
Toronto press they're talking about the
World Press
um and of course they go on and on about
tabloids have their own issues and we
know they do but taboroids a picture is
a picture if you see somebody you can't
fake it actually you can fake it but
newspapers don't
um and what you want to say is okay it
was very difficult but you had a
brilliant position to make the world
better to really make a difference to
really talk about race properly and what
we hear from these do at the moment is
flying in private jets wearing amazingly
beautiful dresses and wonderful jewelry
and what we want to say is what you
don't talk about is the service they say
that every Palace had a publicity to get
good publicity for the Royal Family
well they did want to get good publicity
but often for brilliant causes if you
think of all the things that Prince now
King Charles has supported over the
years they want people to know about all
the causes they do everything from
domestic abuse in the Queen's case to
other things that the family have always
done and they want publicity for that
it's not for them it's for the causes of
the service they provide that so far has
not been mentioned
foreign
well I don't know explain to me why he
would have thought that it was
appropriate to behave in this manner
when uh By the time they'd finished
recording the queen was still alive I
mean what did he expect her majesty what
reaction did he expect from her majesty
well that's one thing Not only was she
alive but of course knew that she was
ill I suspect uh Prince Philip had just
died
um that was horrific and what did he
think the queen would think the queen of
course has been brilliantly a Droid I
mean that wonderful phrase Recollections
do vary after the interview and the way
that she avoided having a picture taken
with the family because she knew it
would be used and used possibly against
her son and the rest of them they took
the Netflix crew to Windsor didn't they
they did yeah and hope for that so and
of course if you remember the minute
they said we wanted worked with you but
we want to live in America and be
outside and she immediately said you
can't be both because of course it's
impossible to do both I don't know where
this is going to end I worry very much
that the next three issues will not be
full of these rather vague things about
the royal family and might be more
direct